So I think one of the really unique things about computer programming is that,
the first time you run your program, it's not going to work. And you shouldn't
expect it to work. And people get really frustrated, because that's not
something that they've seen in other places. And so my advice for anyone
learning to computer program, whatever point you're at, would be to fail
forward. It's about writing code, and running a program, and having it not
compile. And not run. And while that can be really, really frustrating, you'll
see that bug ten times later and you'll understand why that bug is there. And
you'll be faster at it. And in the end, you don't when your program just runs,
because you don't fundamentally understand why that happened. And so. Just fell
forward and learn from your mistakes and be okay with this kind of incremental
process.